and that hangar could just fit the Statue of Liberty in it,
so you get a sense of size of that Falcon Heavy Rocket.
CA: And the fact that there are 27 engines there.
That's part of the design principle
that you, rather than just inventing ever bigger rockets,
you team them up.
GS: It's exactly this residual capability.
We developed the Merlin engine for the Falcon 1 launch vehicle.
We could have tossed that engine
and built an entirely new engine for the Falcon 9.
It would have been called something different,
because Falcon 9 is nine Merlin engines,
but instead of spending a billion dollars on a brand new engine,
we put nine of them together on the back end of Falcon 9.
Residual capability: glue three Falcon 9s together
and you have the largest operational rocket flying.
And so it was expensive to do,
but it was a much more efficient path than starting from scratch.
CA: And the BFR is the equivalent of how much bigger than that,
in terms of its power?
GS: BFR is about, I believe, two and half times the size of this.
CA: Right, and so that allows you --
I mean, I still don't really believe this video that we're about to play here.
What on earth is this?
GS: So it currently is on earth,
but this is basically space travel for earthlings.
I can't wait for this residual capability.
Basically, what we're going to do is we're going to fly BFR like an aircraft
and do point-to-point travel on earth,
so you can take off from New York City or Vancouver
and fly halfway across the globe.
You'll be on the BFR for roughly half an hour or 40 minutes,
and the longest part -- yeah, it's so awesome.
(Applause)
The longest part of that flight is actually the boat out and back.
(Laughter)
CA: I mean. Gwynne, come on, this is awesome, but it's crazy, right?
This is never going to actually happen.
GS: Oh no, it's definitely going to happen.
This is definitely going to happen.
CA: How?
(Applause)
So first of all, countries are going to accept this incoming missile --
(Laughter)
GS: Chris, so can you imagine us trying to convince a federal range,
Air Force bases to take the incomers?
Because we're doing it now, regularly, right?
We're bringing the first stages back,
and we're landing them on federal property on an Air Force base.
So I think doing it, I don't know,
10 kilometers out from a city, maybe it's only five kilometers out from a city.
CA: So how many passengers can possibly afford the fortune
of flying by space?
GS: So the first BFR is going to have roughly a hundred passengers.
And let's talk a little bit about the business.
Everyone thinks rockets are really expensive,
and to a large degree they are,
and how could we possibly compete with airline tickets here?
But if you think about it, if I can do this trip
in half an hour to an hour,
I can do dozens of these a day, right?
And yet, a long-haul aircraft can only make one of those flights a day.
So even if my rocket was slightly more expensive
and the fuel is a little bit more expensive,
I can run 10x at least what they're running in a day,
and really make the revenue that I need to out of that system.
CA: So you really believe this is going to be deployed at some point
in our amazing future. When?
GS: Within a decade, for sure.
CA: And this is Gwynne time or Elon time?
GS: That's Gwynne time. I'm sure Elon will want us to go faster.
(Laughter)
CA: OK, that's certainly amazing.
GS: I'm personally invested in this one, because I travel a lot
and I do not love to travel,
and I would love to get to see my customers in Riyadh,
leave in the morning and be back in time to make dinner.
CA: So we're going to test this out.
So within 10 years, an economy price ticket,
or, like, a couple thousand dollars per person to fly New York to Shanghai.
GS: Yeah, I think it'll be between economy and business,
but you do it in an hour.
CA: Yeah, well, OK, that is definitely something.
(Laughter)
And meanwhile, the other use of BFR is being developed
to go a little bit further than Shanghai.
Talk about this.
You guys have actually developed quite a detailed, sort of, picture
of how humans might fly to Mars,
and what that would look like.
GS: Yeah. So we've got a video, this is a cropped video
from others we've shown, and then there's a couple of new bits to it.
But basically, you're going to lift off from a pad,
you've got a booster as well as the BFS, the Big Falcon Spaceship.
It's going to take off.
The booster is going to drop the spaceship off in orbit,
low earth orbit,
and then return just like we're returning boosters right now.
So it sounds incredible, but we're working on the pieces,
and you can see us achieve these pieces.
So booster comes back.
The new thing here
is that we're going to actually land on the pad that we launched from.
Currently, we land on a separate pad, or we land out on a boat.
Fast, quick connect.
You take a cargo ship full of fuel,
or a fuel depot,
put it on that booster, get that in orbit,
do a docking maneuver, refuel the spaceship,
and head on to your destination,
and this one is Mars.
CA: So, like, a hundred people go to Mars at one time,
taking, what, six months? Two months?
GS: It ends up depending on how big the rocket is.
I think this first version, and we'll continue to make
even bigger BFRs,
I think it's a three-month trip.
Right now, the average is six to eight,
but we're going to try to do it faster.
CA: When do you believe SpaceX will land the first human on Mars?
GS: It's a very similar time frame from the point-to-point.
It's the same capability.
It will be within a decade -- not this decade.
CA: In real time, again, within a decade.
Well, that would also be amazing.
(Laughter)
Why, though? Seriously, why?
I mean, you've got a company where this is the official stated mission.
Has everyone actually bought into that mission,
given that, I mean, there's a lot of people around
who think, come on, you've got so much talent,
so much technology capability.
There are so many things on earth that need urgent attention.
Why would you have this escape trip off to another planet?
(Applause)
GS: So I am glad you asked that,
but I think we need to expand our minds a little bit.
There are plenty of things to do on earth,
but there are lots of companies working on that.
I think we're working on one of the most important things we possibly can,
and that's to find another place for humans to live and survive and thrive.
If something happened on earth,
you need humans living somewhere else.
(Applause)
It's the fundamental risk reduction for the human species.
And this does not subvert
making our planet here better and doing a better job taking care of it,
but I think you need multiple paths to survival,
and this is one of them.
And let's not talk about the downer piece,
like, you go to Mars to make sure all earthlings don't die.
That's terrible, actually, that's a terrible reason to go do it.
Fundamentally, it's another place to explore,
and that's what makes humans different from animals,
it's our sense of exploration and sense of wonderment
and learning something new.
And then I also have to say,
this is the first step in us moving to other solar systems
and potentially other galaxies,
and I think this is the only time I ever out-vision Elon,
because I want to meet other people in other solar systems.
Mars is fine, but it is a fixer-upper planet.
There's work to do there to make it habitable.
(Laughter)
I want to find people, or whatever they call themselves,
in another solar system.
CA: That is a big vision.
Gwynne Shotwell, thank you.
You have one of the most amazing jobs on the planet.
GS: Thank you very much. Thanks, Chris.